[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
make some noise for kevin smith and mark
bernard it's batman beyond
welcome back to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
we are here in hollywood ladies and
gentlemen the only wood that [ __ ]
matters uh at uh the scum and villainy
cantina in
hollywood on hollywood boulevard put
your hands together so the folks at home
know you're a real live audience
um i had just had a cool moment with my
wife i've been married uh 23 years
yesterday as a matter of fact we
celebrated oh happy anniversary
very sweet but um you know you've been
with anybody 23 [ __ ] years it's like
you've seen it all done it all [ __ ]
every armpit whatever the [ __ ] so like
when something new happens you're always
like oh [ __ ]
um you know i don't want to put her in a
bad light or you know have the internet
attacker but she's not been historically
the biggest fan of rick and morty
um and i know what the [ __ ] right like
where can morty happen late into our
marriage if she had told me before we
got married i don't like this rick and
morty i've been like well i don't like
you and we never would have gotten
married so
um whenever i watch it she's like that's
your show so uh just before i left i was
chuckling about something and she's like
what and i was like it's this [ __ ]
thing i saw on rick and morty she's like
oh god
and i was like let me just share it with
you man like [ __ ] it makes me laugh
let me see if it makes you laugh and
she's like [ __ ] fine and so it's the
last episode of the of season five the
one that just ended not too long ago
and uh
if you haven't seen it in the episode
they go back to um
where do they have the council of ricks
the
the
citadel thank you it's a citadel episode
so first they go to the citadel to d-h
morty who's aged himself up to get rick
back home and [ __ ] and the idea in
de-aging him is they bring him to a
place called uh build a morty or rebuild
the morty and so he was aged 50
and they put him in this machine it cuts
them in half
and separates him into two when they're
younger kids and so they've taken the 26
years and gotten rid of the 26 years and
morty comes out the age he's supposed to
be but at the end of the process they're
like um you're going to pay for i hear
an echo
my bad should we keep going or
you're just the voice of god that's cool
you're hearing that though yeah
so weird because when i hear my voice a
few seconds after my voice i don't sound
as interesting as i sound in my head
when i talk
[ __ ] weird so
uh they say like hey uh you know you
gotta pay for the storage of the 26
years that you're leaving behind to take
away regular you know younger morty and
he's like i'm not paying for it he's
like then you got to take it with you
and so they spit out a 26 year old
version of morty and he represents the
20 something
and when he comes out he goes uh i'm i'm
ready almost ready to sell out
and so i i think that's hysterical i
look over my wife and she didn't really
smile and i was like [ __ ] but that's not
the one that i'm [ __ ] going for
that's not the big line
then
something happens outside and the 26
year old morty who's like since he's in
his 20s is kind of virtuous and [ __ ]
like that he goes something unfair is
happening and he runs outside to get
involved and then he winds up getting
shot and killed for his [ __ ] trouble
so young morty is standing over the
dying older version of himself
and then the older version of himself
goes was i
influential
and young morty goes yeah you have like
seven blogs or something and old morty
goes
tight and then dies
and tight is what i've been thinking
about all day just makes me [ __ ]
laugh and that was the thing that i was
like man i hope that makes her [ __ ]
laugh and when he said tight she [ __ ]
cackled out loud and i was like oh my
god thank god we're still [ __ ]
uh so and then i was pushing i was gonna
go for broke because i was like oh [ __ ]
you like that i was like there's one
other line i want to see if it makes you
laugh because if it makes you laugh i'm
gonna incorporate this in our daily
[ __ ] back and forth and [ __ ] and it's
like a few scenes later they go to the
citadel and [ __ ] rick and morty are
eating with the president morty there's
a bunch of ricks infinite ricks infinite
mortys and this infinite morty spoilers
is the evil morty from previous seasons
and stuff and so uh
he's having this kind of very calm back
and forth with rick and rick knows that
something's coming and the way rick
knows everything he's smartest man in
the universe
and so uh at a certain point like you
know rick pulls a gun and he's like i
knew it let's get out of here and he
goes to shoot him or something and the
[ __ ] president morty goes
geez he's a hot bag of peanuts isn't he
and it's always [ __ ] made me laugh so
i was like let me see if this [ __ ]
works on her and i let it play to that
[ __ ] moment and as soon as you know
he said [ __ ] it geez he's a real hot bag
of peanuts isn't he she started cracking
up and [ __ ] and i was like that's the
[ __ ] line
that's what i want to [ __ ] i want to
bring into the relationship it would be
like it'd be more interesting if i was
like i want to bring threesomes into the
relationship but instead i'm like can we
start saying a thing from rick and morty
and i asked for so little i did and she
was like we can do that for you i was
like what a victory um
that happened right before i came here
oh that's why i'm in a good mood happy
anniversary thank you what about you
i i don't have a rick and morty line
that i share with my wife
sorry well you're missing out my friend
oh my god it's very fulfilling get one
yeah instead i i drop a random foghorn
leghorn
every now and again just because i
always loved when he would say that how
boys about a sharp is a box of wet mice
that boy is about as smart as a box of
hammers i just like all of that [ __ ]
cochealisms
so you'll rock that honor oh yeah and
also you guys grew up with that together
right like
that's the same
one way of putting it absolutely
mark for those who are unaware
um was on a show that's not this show
recently he was cheating on me
[ __ ] seth meyers man he went to uh
yes
he went to new york
and he was on late night with seth
meyers tell us about it i i was whined
and dined by nbc [ __ ] yeah cause they
they just like tina fey
just like tina fey who is the sweetest
person she was on your episode she was
on my episode and i'm like so so you get
there
i landed in new york got to my hotel
took the red eye um
you had to not fall asleep because they
were giving me my pre-interview where
they call like a producer will call
right and say hey so
what are we going to talk about with
seth for seven minutes and they will
talk to you for half an hour just like
vetting [ __ ] and you start telling
stories and well how the comic book
happened and i tell the story of that
it's like oh well tell us about working
with your artist and i tell that story
and he's like taking notes so all right
we'll have k we'll have seth ask this
that's standard by the way everybody
does a pre-interview because they want
to make sure you know he's going to be
on for seven minutes they don't want to
like run out of [ __ ] to talk about in
the first two and then he's like so
[ __ ] do you like stuff
so they basically get on the phone with
you for like a half an hour
and some uh somebody who works there in
production has a big conversation with
you and tries to find stuff that they
know
will work as a bit and stuff so
everybody does this yeah it's not just
newbies it's everybody yeah it's not
just like mark's first time so they put
him on with this guy no they everybody
does it make sure he's not going to
vomit on seth do not vomit
and so i i i was staying at hotel that's
like four blocks away from rockefeller
plaza and so i walk over and i just get
my [ __ ] stuff
and i
shh
we hear you guys literally
go ahead mark uh
just take it in the back room go ahead
like
go ahead uh so yeah i walk over to 30
rockefeller plaza yes which
is like i've seen that place a thousand
times like i was a new yorker like i
went to see the tree i i never ice
skated in there because i'm a black dude
and we don't do that but
um like i've walked i've worked in
midtown for 20 years and so but i had
never
been in that building expecting to be on
television inside that place
so i walk over and the little page
greets me and like takes me the elevator
up to the thing i'm sitting in my
dressing room
which again is also super weird because
i don't get dressing rooms anywhere
and uh and there's a knock on my door
and it's tina fey
who's like hey are you mark i'm like
yeah she's like i hear this is your
first time and that you're a writer and
that you're nervous
no
yeah how sweet is that that was adorable
and i'm like well it is my first time
and i'm a writer and yeah i'm a little
bit nervous she's like you'll do fine
seth is a beautiful beautiful man um
when she's not lying he's a handsome man
he is he's very good looking yeah like
frighteningly handsome yeah i expected
like you're a writer too what's with the
skin
but he's got really good skin i mean you
realize that if he wasn't doing that he
could like get laid doing other things
yeah like he don't need a tv show he's
just an attractive dude and he's funny
as [ __ ] very quick i love watching that
show um and so she was like don't worry
you'll do fine seth will take good care
of you i'm gonna go in here and like get
dressed because i gotta wear 14-inch
heels it's like okay bye tina fey i love
you so much
and then craig robinson walks by and
she's like i know him i know you know
him and he just like gives me a dap he's
like you'll do fine be good keep a chin
up like thanks craig
i kept wanting to call him craig t
robinson
mixing him and craig t nelson in the
weirdest way and i'm sure he gets that
all the time yeah are you mr incredible
damn right on mr and grow
and so
then you just kind of wait in the
dressing room and then they're like
uh yeah it's your time uh you gotta go
stand in the chute
wow this echo is real it has a real lou
gehrig [ __ ] feel to it man like
this this this is the greatest greatest
greatest day day of my life life life
what's going on can we just kill that
speaker
is it me it's my voice is the internet
saying anything is the internet mad at
us or we're getting in trouble like
you're echoing your [ __ ] dumb asses
and no spider-man shouldn't have been
one of the 10 films nominated
that still stings i still bring that up
i got a lot of ptsd about that one i was
like really that's what i got crucified
for
uh it sounds like it's gone now
yeah yeah
jc [ __ ] fix it give it up for banff
man man
um okay back to you though so then i
went on the show and i made seth laugh
you did you legit made seth laugh as
somebody who watches that show all the
time like he he he laughed with and at
you not at you like hahaha but like you
said something that made him [ __ ]
laugh and laugh along
and you got the audience too [ __ ] seth
because he's got to be polite and laugh
anyway he'd laugh you made the [ __ ]
audience like legit laugh a couple times
so i was like look at that like
that that's i said to jennifer because i
showed her when she woke up in the
morning i said oh my god watch and i
showed her i was like that is a man who
has been standing in front of audiences
for the last few years and knows how to
[ __ ] control the room [ __ ] pitch a
story like i was so proud of you as if
like i had something to do with it but i
was
you did you do like i've learned at the
feet of the master
you've uh well please let's not use that
term in our relationship just sounds
[ __ ] horrible
not a great look to it but my favorite
thing though is i was going house
shopping over the last like year and a
half yes and there's been a transition
out of using the phrase master bedroom
really yes what do they call it the
primary bedroom
i mean hold on one second just to show
you my white privilege is that where the
term master bedroom comes it is the
biggest bedroom in the plantation house
was where the master slept it was the
master bedroom all right so that's why
racists call it that why do non-racists
call it that because they're the ones
who had the biggest houses and so if you
were like aspiring to wealth those were
the houses you kind of wanted to have
and so when you would build houses in
the suburbs and you want to feel as if
you're the lord of the manor
you get a master bedroom this is the
face of like i can't believe the racism
is so systemically baked in but of
course i wouldn't because i'm you know
i'm not programmed to see it i had no
[ __ ] idea that's where that term came
from yeah so like and and i think it was
you know when we all had the the very
temporary but real awakening about a
year and a half ago about race in
america and things are bad and now we're
trying to put it back in the closet
because we don't talk about anymore but
there was a slight shift
to like
hey so it's now the primary bedroom and
watching real estate agents like stumble
over themselves when i'm walking through
the house
and like they want to say master bedroom
and i'm like ah
do it i dare you i dare you to call it
that come on that's weird i said i never
thought about that that's [ __ ]
fascinating yeah um but at any rate um
no but you
over the course of the time we've been
doing the show because you gotta
remember it wasn't always in front of
people we started at home and then one
day we
and then we we would do it
like on camera first it was audio then
we would do it on camera
and then
detroit is that the first one yeah
during the free film festival
that's right they had to go on the road
let's do a show we did it live and it it
like it worked and people went for it
and stuff but here we do it live
constantly and have been doing it live
here for how long have you been open
banff man is it five years
six years sorry uh give it up for banff
man bam he forgot that
you got flummoxed
uh
five years at the beginning of april
minus the year of covid that we weren't
open but we still did the show from the
closed bar
that's right yeah so i think our first
show was september
2017 here well all the live shows
clearly
like you know it's like anything 10 000
hours of practice malcolm gladwell told
us we'll [ __ ] make you good at
anything you've done it for like 10 000
hours so you were so prepared by the
time you hit that chair you it may have
been your first time but you were no
first timer
and the audience like number one you had
the audience on your side anyway because
you had a charming [ __ ] let me tell
you how i got here story so they already
they were like oh [ __ ] this guy rocks
but you legit like made them laugh
throughout and [ __ ] had moments and
stuff yeah and then i was watching it
and i was like good this is [ __ ]
awesome and you know i'm like five
minutes in nobody's mentioned me what
the [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden [ __ ] he was
like so you do a podcast i was like
that's the thing that i was mostly
concerned about because they didn't say
in the beginning like you know and fat
man beyond because you know that's a
good hit for the podcast oh yeah but he
did get to it like into the interview
and i was like we got the plug we got
the plug
and i fully made up that story yes
fantastic bit
as he told that story jennifer was like
that true i was like no but [ __ ]
that's i'm so proud of them
um lie to the people just a little bit
it was [ __ ] dope i was so [ __ ]
happy for you and he'll have you on
again based on like how he ended it he
wasn't like all right well goodbye
forever right like he uh he liked you uh
that was wonderful man that was [ __ ]
huge he did say like as we were getting
up first he was like so you did you
gonna do any more episodes of the
galactic cast
oh [ __ ] he knew yeah and i was like well
we ran out of galactica he's like yeah
no more galactic is like you should do
the episode of portlandia
um did you ever see the episode of
portland about oh dude do a whole
battlestar galactica yeah
it's about how
fred armisen and forgive me i've always
forget her name so many is the slater
carrie browns carrie brownstein um
playing like later kenny correct isn't
that your part of the world james you
better get that [ __ ] thing right
seriously she's been waiting her whole
life to be like carrie brownstein
and so they play a married couple who uh
who have like run out of [ __ ] to watch
and say like we've heard battlestar
galactic is good and so they put on one
battle galactica and it rapidly devolves
into them burning through battlestar
galactica and not paying any bills
shut down the cable they got to
negotiate to get their cable back the
electricity is shut down they like light
a generator in the backyard all to
finish battlestar galactica and then
they get to the end of it and they run
out of battlestar galactica and we're
like well it can't be over let's make
ron moore write us more battlestar
galactica and so then they had like
[ __ ] ron moore shows up on the show
to tell them like one more episode they
hold him hostage and then um james
callis is there as baltar oh my god and
so it's this weird little
like
nested baby sequel to battlestar on
portlandia that makes no sense but it's
so wonderful
you should do that do that as an app
you're gonna do it um we gotta find a
new place to host it because sci-fi was
our home and they don't do podcasts
anymore and so like i just i want to
take the podcast back and find a new
home for it and then we'll do one more
episode
to christen the new home do you get to
take the podcast back is it yours
i believe it's in our contract the
standard rich and famous contract we
signed with uh nbc universal [ __ ] hey
man well if you need a place to stick it
i know a guy with a podcast network you
know
name is joe rogan
he's very wealthy from what i understand
i i think we would get along famously
joe and i yes
no doubt look at this [ __ ] man the
beautiful thing when people
stick stuff on the bar and this is like
let me tell you something right now this
is a little [ __ ] side tip ooh
fat man beyond
fat man beyond probably the best value
dollar value uh in terms of like if you
want to interact with or see
the likes of kevin smith because not
only is it like a close
intimate proximity everybody like you
could throw a tissue at me and shatter
my face
um everyone so go ahead don't you try it
chan um
not only is everything close and stuff
but this is unique of all the shows i do
is the only
time that this occurs where people pile
stuff on the bar
to get signed now
if i'm somebody who knows how to like
[ __ ] upsell an item that's been
signed what does the ticket to this
place cost
twenty five bucks doesn't come in 25
bucks for 25 bucks you could get like
[ __ ]
four pop sign turn around sell those for
like two three hundred bucks
so i always thought like that's [ __ ]
smart like some people put up their own
personal [ __ ] that's great but some
people put up multiples i don't judge i
don't give a [ __ ] i just sign whatever's
in front of me you can put up divorce
papers and i just [ __ ] sign them and
but what delights me is when i see [ __ ]
like this this is this one of the things
they you know used to hang in the movie
theater now these are going away because
they're all digital now and you can put
like a moving image like a harry potter
picture up there so not only is this
like a relic of the past but it's one
that like they didn't make a lot of
these
uh dogma [ __ ] and there must be a
term of art for what these actually are
mylars it's made of mylar but they i
guess they do refer to it just as the
mylars um i ain't seen this since like
1999.
so the fact that somebody brought it
here uh has delighted me who who bought
that you brought this
fantastic i'm gonna keep this now
uh in any event can you sign that to
mark yes
what is the uh what else you do when you
were in new york uh
let's see i ate because every time i go
back to new york it becomes like the
food tour of new york so i gotta get
pizza and bagels and chinese food
and so i got the i got the pizza and the
chinese food out of the way after seth
meyers and then the next day went
outside after you didn't eat before you
went out today no
i didn't either i didn't need the sauce
shits just trying to get on seth myers
yes i'm always the same way though like
you want to eat i'm like before i go on
camera what are you nuts i was like as
soon as i'm done talking though i'm
gonna gorge man but like beforehand
never and it's a shame because they
always like hook you up with good [ __ ]
did they offer you booze
they did not there's a lot of talk shows
i don't maybe post pandemic they don't
do it but back in the day man [ __ ]
going to tonight's show they brought a
bar cart to your [ __ ] room but i
don't drink so i was always like i'm
good can i smoke weed they're like not
in here
yeah call me when there's a weed wagon
right yeah
can you roll up with some [ __ ]
indicas and [ __ ] let me know
um
what uh what else you do in new york uh
and then i went to go see my folks like
my parents and my brother all live on on
long island so i
tuesday was seth meyers wednesday was
hanging out with the folks and then then
i [ __ ] got back on a plane and came
back to l.a had to come back to [ __ ]
horrible reality and [ __ ] yeah wasn't it
weird like [ __ ] you come off like the
talk show right and you're like holy
[ __ ] i was just on a show with a guy
that i watch and in your case you're
like it wasn't even like i was forced to
do this by some other company you're
like i want it to [ __ ] be there
and when it's all done and [ __ ] aren't
you like
i can't go to sleep i could [ __ ] do
anything
uh yeah a little bit of that except i
was also crazy jet lag so i did just go
to sleep
so the that's the other thing where it's
like you've worked yourself up and then
[ __ ] once it's done you're like ah
yeah sugar crash plus
egg rolls
all those damn egg rolls i uh while
we've been away from the show
i've been deep in the world of comic
cons
back on the road yeah i went to the
puerto rico comic con a couple weeks ago
which was beautiful you ever been to
puerto rico yes
well there you go um i was about to do
20 minutes on it but i'm glad you've
been there it's [ __ ] gorgeous i said
to him when i was there i was like this
the [ __ ] water here is beautiful i
said i've not seen water this blue since
i was like nine years old and my parents
took our whole family to the caribbean
when i was a kid and they're like you're
in the caribbean
and i learned something i had no idea
puerto rico was in the caribbean and
sure um
i think it was like a mile and a half
off of new york i guess
you know i guess i thought it was like a
florida kind of thing like a florida
island or whatever the [ __ ] but it's
like legit in the caribbean though like
this is the caribbean i was like like
pirates of the caribbean
and they're like yeah they're like i was
like i'm sorry everything i know about
history is based on like disney and [ __ ]
and they're like that's not fake like
that happened there are people who are
here who are descendants of blackbeard
and i was like is that [ __ ] true like
yeah he was a real guy and he [ __ ] so
yeah there are people here that [ __ ]
are related to pirates but this guy also
told me about he's fascinating manny he
ran security he uh he also told me about
the thing nobody talks about or everyone
talks about pirates they don't talk
about corsairs do you ever hear about
these cats
the privateers courses yeah yeah they
got hired to hunt the pirates now i
didn't watch all those [ __ ] parts of
the caribbean movies was that a part of
the plot like were there did they hire
did they reference corsairs they didn't
but there were members of the sort of
royal navy whose job it was like they
were after them right they were still
attendants and a duties to that i found
that so fascinating like like you know
that part i never heard about growing up
you always heard about pirates and [ __ ]
but never like and then they hired
people that are essentially like the
first police to be like go out and get
these [ __ ] guys that stole their [ __ ]
it's crazy so i learned a bunch of [ __ ]
about puerto rico the show was wonderful
i'm gonna take the
movie there when we tour in the fall
clerks three because it's only like two
hour [ __ ] flight from florida my
whole life i thought puerto rico was
like you gotta cross the international
time zone or some [ __ ] but really it's
like a two-hour [ __ ] flight so that
was eye-opening and fun uh and then i
also i went to the philly comic-con like
right the week before that that was
great fan expo philly and then this
weekend i went to the weekend that just
passed uh calgary expo which is their
big [ __ ] comic con so i've been deep
in it man and it's been nice to go back
to
shows like it's crazy who you see i was
it i was in the
i never go into the green room because
you know they just got food there and i
i'm not gonna eat before i do anything
and all the food ain't vegan anyway and
[ __ ] it's just best i stay away from the
food but at the end of the show uh i had
to meet juliet back there because they
give you like loot and stuff like that
so i was in the green room waiting for
it and as i walked in i saw brendan
frazier
sitting there and he was
i g like i saw him sitting there with a
woman
and i thought they were in conversation
and [ __ ] so as i you know i was going to
walk past but i'm like you know man i
never engage people but like i had a
story for this guy
so i stopped and i i like tapped him on
there i'm not like hey
you know but just kind of like hey man i
said uh i mean i don't mean to interrupt
that i apologize to the lady i'm sorry
but i just want to tell them i was like
one time years ago
i was at the four seasons hotel
in new york and i was getting onto an
elevator as my wife and my kid was with
me and you were getting off the elevator
and this was at the height of [ __ ]
you and the mummy movies
and doors open and you got this
delighted expression when you saw him
and you're like kevin smith whoa how are
you
and i said hey man how are you and then
i got in the elevator and you left and
that was the first time that my kid was
like what do you do
like how do you know [ __ ] you know
rick o'connell know who you are exactly
how do you know george of the jungle and
[ __ ] like that
was that encino man how do you know him
and my wife too was just like you know
because [ __ ]
the mummies were huge she was like why
would a man in a blockbuster know your
name
and i was like respect so you know i
told them i was like honestly dude that
was one of the coolest things uh that
happened to me like in new york ever and
it impressed the [ __ ] out of my kid so i
just want to say thank you and i turned
back to the woman and i was like again
i'm so sorry for interrupting my wife
hates it when people like bomb in
between us and they just start talking
to me and stuff so i i realize i'm being
that exact person and brendan frazier
goes kevin i wasn't even talking to her
i don't know who this person is
because you could you could stop
apologizing they're just sitting there
and the woman went like this and i was
like all right my bad
so i asked him i was like um he was
lovely he was like that's so sweet thank
you so much i said how was
batgirl and he was like it was really
great man good time i think it's been a
good movie he's going the i was like how
was the director and he goes the
directors i was like that's right there
were two of them he was like they were
absolutely wonderful and then he talked
a big [ __ ] about the girl what's her
name leslie leslie grace leslie grace
he's like she's wonderful she could do
it all blah blah blah
um but it was sweet and then i was like
hey man great seeing you and i i thought
like oh i should take a [ __ ] picture
but i felt like i held them up so long
what a lovely [ __ ] dude though
absolutely [ __ ] lovely dude so it's
nice to be back in con world and like
seeing people like i saw robert england
i was like holy [ __ ] john cleese went to
the [ __ ] calgary expo really yeah
where i was like i've never seen a
python in real life and [ __ ] so that was
kind of dope um so yeah it's been neat i
go to cleveland this weekend uh for fan
expo cleveland may 7th and 8th the
following week i'm in new jersey for jay
and zombop secret stash silver
anniversary bash
and then the weekend after that i think
i'm at st louis fan expo and then
orlando megacon so i get to go see my
mom but it's a lot of cons me and jay
signed up for a bunch of cons this year
to a to prep for clerk's three release
uh and b because i knew we were going to
release uh secret stash press so it's
like i might as well get back deep into
the world and it's been fun it's been
absolutely bliss and i've been taking
pictures with like
muse has been asking me to go to cons
for years i you know i've been going to
comic cons for years but generally for
the last five years for imdb i'd be on
the imd boat and interview people at san
diego so i don't really get to [ __ ]
around with the floor and [ __ ] i go into
the con to do my haul h panel but that's
about it
so for years jay was like why don't you
come to these other cons with me man i
was like why it'd be fun he goes no i'd
make so much more money if you were
there man
and so finally i was like you know what
i'm going to go to these cons because we
need to like start promoting for the
movie and he was like oh i'm going to
get rich and so
he has been delightful it's so
accommodating he's always checking in on
him he's like you're right you need
anything because he likes that i'm there
because he's like collecting big time
and [ __ ] so he's just like everybody
gives you problems you let me know
this is my world i got the hook up and
[ __ ] and i was like this is my world
before it was your world you said well
kind of the same time but whatever i
don't want to upset you
enjoy to come so it's been it's been fun
man it's been a good time but i've
missed doing this we haven't been able
to do this for a few weeks when was the
last time we did a live show banff man
uh i think april 3rd
where was that
streamed that was stream that was at
home a month ago it would have been a
month ago we've been here nice to be
back with everybody always hopefully we
don't get covered let's put our hands
together for that
um all right
before we dive into uh what i'm sure we
got news there must be a sponsor there's
always a sponsor god willing yes no
kidding there are two sponsors oh [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] lucky i know it um first
we're going to talk about the good folks
at stance
stance i thought of them all the time
while i was on my trip because all my
trips because i got uh the hat they they
sent me some socks and a hat as a sample
and the [ __ ] hat is wonderfully
comfortable and so when i fly you know i
wear the backwards baseball cap but when
you sit in a
chair this is gonna sound like first
world problems when you sit in the chair
the back of the [ __ ] hat hits the
back of the chair so i could spin my hat
around but i look like an absolute dick
if i do that says the guy wearing horns
on his head right now
so
when i'm on the plane i swap out the hat
for the stance hat and i'm wearing like
this [ __ ]
two little [ __ ] a little beanie and
feeling [ __ ] like a 20 something i'm
like tight
hotter than a bag of peanuts is that it
yes yeah yeah it's like it's be sure is
a hot bag of peanuts hot bag of peanuts
um the good folks at stance they make
socks
they make [ __ ] hats what else do they
make
they make sweatpants and joggers which
once upon a time were only meant to be
worn around the house or at the gym but
now stance has made them cool
thank god somebody finally did because i
used to wear sweatpants all the time in
high school and it was not cool
no no i i i started back in a writer's
room this week on a new television
program yeah i saw that you got a job
were you on the disney lotto i saw an
image of mickey mouse on the disney lab
working for the mouse working for the
mouse all done but now i got to put a
belt on every [ __ ] day because i've
been rocking sweatpants for the last two
years oh you gotta get dressed i gotta
get dressed you don't wear sweatpants
they don't care
man not day one though that's true you
get you gotta ease back in that's the
same where you're like i gave up a long
time ago let's write
what you got ideas and slacks
um
no
stance is making a full line of
sweatpants joggers hoodies and more that
you'll be proud to be seen wearing
wherever and whenever but not just
making sucks anymore stance apparel is
all really soft and comfortable with
some very interesting designs legit soft
had i know we were going to be
advertising for tonight i would have
brought my hat with me man it's also
this is going to sound weird and too
much information maybe stance don't want
this maybe they'll sell a [ __ ] cap or
two what's their website
uh let's see stance.com stan well that's
easy
s-t-a-n-c-e dot com is that correct that
is indeed okay so it's not just my plane
hat it's also my [ __ ] hat because i
can't [ __ ] a baseball cap i tried but
my wife's like take that off but i don't
if i just horns are making it weird
exactly i'm like this and she's like oh
[ __ ] this
so you know you take your hat off your
hats your hair's all matted and [ __ ] and
that's like when you're looking your
least [ __ ] sexy like kiss me and i
got all this greasy matted hair so i
take that hat off and i put on my stance
hat and [ __ ] so used to be back in the
day i'd come out of the bathroom
brushing my teeth and that's how my wife
knew it was time we were gonna [ __ ]
because she's like anytime you want to
[ __ ] just brush your teeth and i was
like done and done and i brushed my
teeth so rarely that that counts
but now i just put on the [ __ ] hat
and she's like oh i know what time it is
and she closes the curtains and we go at
it so get yourself a stance hat
and [ __ ] in it that's what i do
good for warmth i also wore it in
calgary this weekend not to [ __ ] but
just i went outside to smoke and it was
chilly and i put on this toque and it
kept me warm this stance hat has so many
uses on a plane
[ __ ] [ __ ]
head warmth yeah [ __ ] and natural
headboard this hat works the way it
should
uh i'm going to skip half of what they
wanted us to say because they're like
don't talk about that yeah no no uh
stance's philosophy is that you should
never have to sacrifice your own
individual style for the sake of comfort
and now you don't have to well that's my
philosophy as well in it though look how
that jives whether you're relaxing
around the house working out at the gym
or running all over town stance now
delivers its signature softness and
creativity in a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head sans has
got you covered head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code fatman at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different i can't tell
you how much i like this [ __ ] hat
kids probably because i get to have sex
in it a lot but regardless stance makes
a good product go to stance.com uh show
them your support man we thank the good
folks at stance for taking a stance for
fat man beyond put your hands together
for the stance folks
um all right time for some news
time for some news mark bernardin ladies
and gentlemen he was a news hound once
upon a [ __ ] yesteryear and [ __ ] now
as you heard it he's working at disney
and we're not going to pry to find out
what that is but
yeah i'm not gonna tell either because
i'd like to keep working at disney smart
plan uh but before he did all that he
was a guy that would uh
write news stories he was a news
gatherer if you will a newsman and uh
every once in a while we ask mark to dig
back into the past uh and find those
hidden skills that never go away it's
like writing but jesus intro is long
give it up for mark he's got the news
man
before we go too deep into the news it's
been a couple of weeks since we talked
about moon night
um yes it has and moon night has
continued to [ __ ] impress uh one of
my favorite of the marvel shows has it
look everybody knew that i would
continue liking it yeah i think everyone
was surprised you liked the first one
yes
did you continue to like it or have you
been like
let's hear the update it's a bitter
[ __ ] i knew it
you know this was i knew it was too good
to be true
yeah i mean my my the thing that i that
i discovered in the second episode is
that stephen is such a whiny [ __ ] i
want less of stephen les steven graham
less steven grant and i wanted mark to
like
sit in the driver's seat a bit more and
do some cool [ __ ] and he kind of almost
never does
um
and i kept losing the threat of what the
threat of the season was right because
it never seems to be important to
anybody
you're like well we got to get to amit's
tomb okay how are we going to do it the
scarab we lost a scab oh well i guess
we're going to cairo now sure did we
need the scarab to go to cairo
no but now we like it it becomes a
little it gets bogged down in itself a
little bit um i liked the most recent
episode the tune
um because it was the mummy speak of the
devil it's just like we're [ __ ]
raiding a tomb and there's mummies and
sarcophagi and and crazy zombie egyptian
creatures and like that's all pretty
great
and then you get to the ending of that
episode and
and i'm
concerned
because
there's i as i see it there's two ways
to read that finale did everybody here
see the last episode of moon night
yeah if you haven't [ __ ] you it was
wednesday
i know there's a lot going on in the
world but come on that was wednesday
today's tuesday you had six days spoil
it we're coming late and so we we return
after mark spector gets shot in the
chest
by arthur haro harrow um and now we're
in like an insane asylum we're in a some
kind of
mental facility mental health is when my
wife jumped back on board she's like
they have my attention now and i was
like oh good for you i said i've always
loved it so [ __ ] you johnny come lately
so as i interpreted it and i could i'm
happy to be wrong yes that that final
sequence is either
a judgment on the part of the egyptian
gods to see if mark specter stephen
grant is worthy of whatever right
or
it's saying that the last four episodes
up until that point have taken place
solely in mark steven slash third
identity we haven't met yet mind that
was what they were leading us to believe
i think by showing us like here this
picture in the doctor's office this
looks like the
bavarian town he was in hey the doctor's
got a cane that resembles the [ __ ]
crocodile king there was a lot of that
kaiser soze [ __ ] right where you were
like oh is this a mind [ __ ] but i don't
buy it i mean honestly i feel like
they're getting ready to introduce the
third personality if you read the comics
there's a third guy named jake locksley
right so it could be that they're
getting ready to bring that guy because
if you remember correctly
one of the episodes
stephen
well no mark wakes up and finds people
dead and he looks in the reflection and
steven's like i didn't do this
so if mark didn't do and stephen didn't
do it
maybe it's the third personality and
maybe that has something to do with you
know the white room we were in yeah and
they do introduce the idea that the
various personalities are sleeping in
sarcophagi
and there was another sarcophagus
somebody's like rattling on the inside
that we don't see who's inside
but i just don't want to have spent
three and a half episodes of television
in a thing that wasn't real
and have wait a second mark
it isn't real
it's all real kevin i don't know how to
bring this to you but [ __ ]
it's okay if it's not real because it's
not real it reminds me of like when we
were kids and [ __ ] you'd be like
[ __ ] that's not the real superman
because superman couldn't fly backwards
around the world and turn back time
that's stupid but he can leap tall
buildings in a single bound and [ __ ]
that's smart yeah
i mean in for a penny in for a pound i
say
um so yeah i just i i i'm never that
fond of that kind of bait and switch
where i had been invested in one story
and you tell me that that story isn't
what the story was and it's actually
this thing and so none of the stuff you
are really paying attention to counts
that much true and so i started paying
attention to how many times we depart
from stephen and or mark and we follow a
third character who would not have
access to this particular delusion
and it was enough
to make me feel that all right well we
wouldn't be hanging out with layla alone
if this was mark imagining it or stephen
imagining themselves in the center of
this agreed story so i'm like okay so
then maybe it is the judgment maybe it
is
you know mark stephen is on the brink of
death and he is in some netherworld some
limbo very loss-like having to go
through some kind of adventure to either
regain his humanity or synthesize his
personalities or whatever the [ __ ] it is
sidebar previewed vhs copy blockbuster
of dogma wow [ __ ] this is ancient
right here
uh back to you um so like i i i'm just
hoping because i know that
this series has felt very much as if
it's
it's in pairs like episode one and two
was a pair if it says three and four was
a pair and five and six will be a pair
and so we ended four with
you know here's our other personality
here's an awesome what seems to be hippo
uh egyptian god do you know what that is
by any chance anybody know what that is
is that a marvel reference that i'm
unfamiliar with i think it's a deep
egyptian reference to a specific god
that was one thing my wife was like ooh
who's that i'm like i don't know
and normally i'm the guy who can answer
everything when we watch the show yeah
that's matter eater lad
no well at one point i was like do shops
and i was like holy [ __ ] and she was
like what's that i was like he's got a
butler in the comics named frenchy
that's his alfred and [ __ ] and his name
is duchamp's like seeing his name in the
phone that's [ __ ] blah blah and she's
like do you ever watch the show are you
just watching the show behind the show
and i was like i could do both
um so yeah like i'm i'm i'm
i'm in i haven't like abandoned hope in
the show i'm still watching right but
i'm just hoping that it's
as i hope with every show that rewards
the faith and the feel that you give it
by playing fair with the audience who
came to it um i have uh no complaints
about the show whatsoever but i will
note that they did not
show moon night last week
there was no moon night whatsoever he
didn't [ __ ] no you know summon the
suit once that's still one of my
favorite sequences of the show some in
the suit and he [ __ ] pulls up the mr
knight suit i know some people in comics
are like hey man that ain't the real mr
knight but i'm like he looks like it
he's not acting like it but you know
maybe they'll get there once the jake
lockley locksley personality comes in
that is also what i'm hoping because the
moon knight that we've seen is not that
cool yet
like he's not doing that much great
stuff like i jumped from a roof and i
beat you up a little bit but it's not as
if there's like awesome superheroes
should happen he keeps whipping moons at
[ __ ] man that's awesome he pulls him
off his chest and he [ __ ] holds him
like weapons he did that once though man
it's enough is it though
in a show called moon night i want more
moon knight a little bit more moon night
front or back
whose is this
back oh hello captain how are you
i'll we'll plug that in a second
um this is look this is uh orco
made by children uh children's children
the artist not by children although he
is quite childish um
gorgeous piece uh you gave me one of
these then i took it to give to griffin
who plays orco griffin newman and he
goes i have one
he's got [ __ ] one man so you know
that was kind of dope it's gorgeous
[ __ ] piece
uh he also did the silent ball over the
kevin smith guru rescue i'll show you in
a minute anyway
um i
i my bar is not as high as yours mark
and as long as they keep referencing
things
from the comic books like i'm like oh
that's that
that's that and
you know my wife uh which one the black
shirt this one sure uh my wife you know
was kind of like you know she loved
episode one and then she kind of has
drifted a little bit she's like i don't
know what's going on and for me i'm like
neither do i but i don't give a [ __ ]
um
what happens after this is done because
they've done four episodes so far three
four and there's only two more
what's the next marvel series anybody
know
marvel happens after that yeah but first
obi-wan correct
yes
um they're still killing it as far as
i'm concerned i like it i i wrote down a
bunch of [ __ ] that i watched because
i'll never remember so i wrote a list
please and also
there's somebody hold on i wrote the
kid's name down
i was in calgary
and the guy was like i [ __ ] love fat
man beyond
eh
i was like all right calm down and uh
and uh i was like you want me to say
your name on the show he goes [ __ ] yeah
his name is cody
cody from calgary i told you i'd
reference you on the show give it up for
cody from calgary
uh okay here's all the stuff i've
watched or have been watching uh i've
talked about we crashed previously
they finished anne hathaway deserves a
[ __ ] i know it was a streaming tv
show give her an oscar that's how great
her performance is i know
you know she's great actors people have
always loved her but this was the first
thing that i saw where i was like jesus
that is a real person that's not a
performance she she was great uh worth
it just to watch her alone i watched the
documentary white hot about abercrombie
and fitch ooh really [ __ ] fascinating
i didn't know much about it and [ __ ] i
think it's on i don't know if it's on
hulu or if it's on netflix but it was
really [ __ ] interesting and full of
like late 90s early 2000s music
um
i watched uh the thing about pam with
renee zellweger in a fat suit really
good fun
uh hbo has a new show called we own this
city from the same people that did the
wire david simon david simon uh
so far so good one episode's got john
barenthal you can't protect a wreck he's
in it
also worth watching uh we watched this
thing called cursed films
it was a shutter miniseries uh it's
still going i think they drop one a week
or something it's in its second season
and they it's like a 30 to 45 minute
documentary about horror movies that are
also cursed so they did a whole episode
about poltergeist they did a whole
episode about rosemary's baby the omen
any movie that had like you know some
[ __ ]
die someone even the wizard of oz you
know that some of the weird things
happened there excellent [ __ ] little
series man i think it's on shutter
definitely worth watching documentary
series speaking of documentary i saw his
documentaries not new but it's worth
looking for um
let's do a deep dive on uh who's got
directed the [ __ ]
king of khan doc king of kong
documentary seth
gordon is that his name yeah could be
wrong he he was a director who made that
documentary of the king of kong and then
he transitioned into features and he did
like four christmases and movies that
have made a lot of money and stuff so i
was like what happened to that guy and
then i so i was looking at his all his
work and [ __ ] and there was a
documentary he produced which i'd never
heard about and so i was like i'm gonna
give this a spin and it was [ __ ]
mind-bending it's called finders keepers
and it's such an involved story takes
place in north carolina so everybody has
an accent and the idea is this one guy
like he had a tragic life and and he got
in a plane crash with his dad and he
lost his leg
so when they amputate you know your body
part
they're supposed to keep it
but he was like can i have it when we're
done and they were like because i you
know maybe it's because they were where
they were in the world but they were
like sure
and they gave him his [ __ ]
calf wrapped up in [ __ ] plastic with
you know cut from below the knee or
whatever the [ __ ] or above the knee
and so he did a kind of
draping like in uh
like fiberglassing of it and let it sit
in formaldehyde he mummified his own leg
essentially mummified his own leg so he
could keep it and [ __ ] and then he put
it
in a a
smoker like that you put a pig in and
smoke it for barbecue
and on his that's where he stored it for
whatever reason never occurred to him
put it in the freezer or something
whatever the [ __ ]
so then he falls on some financial hard
times he puts all of his [ __ ] into a
storage facility
and then falls on further financial hard
times so the storage facility does one
of those auctions where they're like who
wants to buy all this [ __ ] this one guy
wins the storage facility
goes in finds a smoker opens it up finds
a [ __ ] human leg in it
picks it up and this guy he's like very
entertaining he's talking on he's like i
was picking it up and all the
cholesterol was dripping out
kept he said that if he said cholesterol
once he said it five times whatever he
whatever the formaldehyde he kept
calling it cholesterol so this guy finds
this leg and he calls the cops it's like
i think i found a human leg and smoker i
just bought it at this [ __ ] garage so
and so they come get it like that's a
human lego right and they take it back
to you know [ __ ] uh the morgue or
whatever the [ __ ] while they try to
figure out what the [ __ ] happened
so
the guy who is like it was
they they reach out to him they're like
hey did you have a [ __ ] human leg and
a smoker at this [ __ ] storage field
he's like yeah it was my leg and he
tells him the story and [ __ ] and like
what are you doing with a [ __ ] leg
and he's like this gave it to me after
the operation i asked for it and he gave
it to me and stuff and he's like well
some guy bought your [ __ ] story he's
like oh that guy bought it yeah my leg's
in there bummer
so then they have to tell the other guy
like yeah we found a guy whose leg it is
it's his leg he just stores it in the
smoker
and then the guy who bought all the [ __ ]
and the smoker is like well i want the
leg back it's my property
and they're like why do you want it and
he's like because i got people coming
here to my house i'm charging five bucks
to look at the smoker where the leg was
i could charge 10 if the leg is still in
it
documentary about these two dudes
fighting over this one guy's [ __ ] leg
fascinating so worth your watch kids
finders keepers it was called i mean
feels like it could have been a podcast
but okay
i'm telling you it was it was like it
was
endlessly entertaining and also just
like what like really kind of about how
badly some people want to be famous
because the guy who like you know bought
the leg
like he started making shirts up like
[ __ ] the
you know as a tourist trapping [ __ ] is
crazy um
the dropout which was wonderful
she should get an award amanda seyfried
she was [ __ ] fantastic without doing
an impression of elizabeth holmes she
evoked her
you know in performance absolutely
wonderful and then uh barry just started
last night
with bill hader came back on hbo uh that
was very strong the girl from plainville
on uh hulu which is about the girl that
you know
texas with the but yeah that girl from
plainville uh the girl who texted with
the boy who was thinking of killing
himself and she was like get back in the
car that [ __ ] um what's her name one of
the fanning girls not elephant l fanning
not dakota she plays elite she's
wonderful and the last thing i saw i
actually went to a movie theater
to see yesterday for my anniversary and
it was a
singular
cinematic experience to say the least
every once in a while you see a movie
that's so [ __ ] startlingly original
you can't even [ __ ] tell the story
like i could sit there and tell you
finders keepers
about the dude losing the leg i cannot
[ __ ] explain to you bless you
um
everything everywhere all at once
has everyone has anyone seen this movie
put your hands together oh my god do you
see it yes
what a staggering motion picture this is
every step of the way not just the movie
you're watching but the life behind the
movie as i sit there going how did this
[ __ ] get made how did this filmmaker
get to be like i'm gonna go with
michelle yo
and i'm gonna go with short round
and we're gonna make like one of the
greatest movies ever [ __ ] seen how
they ran the gauntlet without somebody
being like well don't you want margot
robbie or something like that he got or
they the two directors there daniels
yeah daniel and daniel something um have
made
a breathtakingly
uh heartbreakingly
original movie predicated on concepts
that we who like this [ __ ] genre and
comics and stuff
are overly familiar with they took
something old and made it completely
[ __ ] new
um while making something brand new that
you've never seen before it's a miracle
it's a modern miracle a little work of
art man and i honestly
can't sell it to you i told my wife i
was just like i've been hearing nothing
about good thing number good things but
about this i don't know how to sell it
to you so let's just go see it and then
when we saw it i was like i wouldn't
even know how to explain that movie to
somebody yeah like i don't understand
how they pitched that movie like how do
you convince somebody to give you 20
million dollars to make that because
it's not an expensive movie it was a
relatively small budget
but it's so
[ __ ] weird in the most elementally
beautiful way very and and it makes
these jumps and logic and structure and
all and it's it is everything everywhere
all at once
it's exactly the experience of watching
the movie because sometimes you're in
the life of this
sort of mid-50s
mother and husband who's taking care of
her elderly father um
played by the great james hung
um
and and
then it's she's a a
sort of hong kong actress let's just
let's try to do it justice see if you
can yeah it's [ __ ] doing about this
it starts very normal with a family
that's like going into the irs to
try to deal with their finances their
accounting and perhaps maybe open a new
business because they want to expand
they run a laundromat it's a married
couple
uh michelle yo and
kihu kwan kihoi kwan
the boy boy he's a grown ass man now but
the guy who played [ __ ]
short round and he was also in data data
and the goonies as well
so we were just talking about him not
too long remember we were talking about
if they do a short round show he should
play old short round and then they get
somebody um
real quick yeah bam fans here ladies and
gentlemen must be important this guy's
returning to acting after how many years
uh like almost 30. 30 years
is it a coincidence that indiana jones 5
is filming right now also do you think
[ __ ] that's a possibility it has to
right
you know i wouldn't put that above james
mangle james mangold is a wonderful
filmmaker who's a great writer as well
and if that dude was like oh we could
[ __ ] work short round into this
that'd be a hell of a piece of fan
service and based on what
the gentleman did in everything
everywhere all at once he hasn't missed
a [ __ ] beat i mean look he's better
than he was as data i know that
sacrilege everyone likes the goonies but
he's grown as a performer it's not like
well this dude hasn't acted in decades
he was absolutely [ __ ] wonderful i
hope he is i hope you're right i hope
they put him in that next indiana jones
movie he'd be an asset particularly
after this this is about to become 824's
highest grossing film
so
starts very normally and then
the other worldly [ __ ] begins as her
husband starts telling her
that he's from another dimension and
gives her a very matrix-like you know
set of directions and if you want to
change your life go right go left and it
it falls down the rabbit hole
of fantasy
and
multiversity
you know there's a bit of sliding doors
to it in terms of like what would my
life have been like if i hadn't but it's
sliding doors times a thousand because
you get to see just like rick and morty
how there's infinite ricks and infinite
mortys there are infinite versions of us
across the multiverse and throughout the
movie our main character will access
a different version of herself somewhere
across the multiverse in order to do
what she has to do so if she has to
fight somebody with martial arts she's a
woman who's like worked a laundromat her
whole life she's not a fight but she can
access a different version of her in
another multiverse who is a famous movie
star essentially michelle yo
who knows how to do all forms of martial
arts
download it and essentially then do the
martial arts yourself it's
[ __ ] wonderful but it's all balanced
against because you sit there going
is this about the the normal story it's
in the normal story there's a very
normal banal
you know incident that i wouldn't say
predicates everything but
you know it's
it's something that in there is it's
divorce and it's something you wouldn't
want to think about in the real world
says you're watching the movie you're
like is this person trying to avoid
their reality by coming up with this
fiction in their head but it's actually
happening in and around everybody in the
movie like they don't cheap out it's not
them going like it was all just in one
person's head it's it's an adventure
it's a massive massive human adventure
that looks at
the
the
all the potential that we have in this
life
and others it has one of the most
beautiful
lines devastating movie will make you
laugh it'll make you cry there's a lot
of emotional [ __ ] but one of the lines i
don't know if it'll make [ __ ] sense
but like our main characters
you know in the real world work at this
laundromat and they're dealing with the
[ __ ] irs and their taxes
the one version of the couple in the
multi versus michelle yo is this famous
movie star and her husband in the real
world in our world
like they had a star crawl i'm gonna cry
talking about they had a star-crossed
moment the moment in her real life her
father was like don't [ __ ] marry this
guy if you marry this guy i'm gonna
throw you out of the family and she went
with him and married him regardless in
this other reality she did not go with
them and she became [ __ ] world famous
she's like this massive movie star and
he shows up at the premiere of the movie
and he was like i was wondering if you
would remember me and she's like how
could i forget you and they have this
conversation and it's oh it's tough they
have this conversation where at the end
of it you know she's talking she's
trying to explain to him she's like i'm
here and i'm not here like there's
another world where
like i did say yes to you and
you know
all we do is run a shitty family laundry
and worry about doing our taxes and like
10 minutes later he delivers this line
back to where he goes
um
i would have been completely okay in any
reality where all we did was laundry and
taxes together
[ __ ] beautiful line as a writer i was
just like oh i grabbed my wife's leg i
was like god damn it like [ __ ] i'll
never write a line as beautiful as that
and she was like you're right you won't
um
it's really really [ __ ] wonderful i i
and we're not doing it justice it is
you know
you can't really compare it to something
there's no antecedent it's a true a24
film because it's like [ __ ] this breaks
the mold but it's also
it's also an independent film that is at
its core very small
it's very small and emotional it's about
a family that's twisting itself apart
yes because of convention and because of
sort of history and because of
dogma and all that stuff
it also happens to be this crazy
dimension hopping martial arts science
fiction mind bender
but
it's about those emotions it's about
those people and i don't think
there is an actor in the world who could
have done this movie aside from michelle
yeah agreed you know i mean i know that
the the daniels had done a bunch of
press about it and they said that they
originally wrote it for jackie chan
is that right yeah it was supposed to be
jackie chan and then i think daniel quan
who's a half of the daniels was like ah
you know i feel like i want it to be
about a mother and a daughter and a
mother and a husband and i wanted to
root it in that and we don't get that
with jackie chan but we get it with
michelle yo and they both have the same
amount
of pop culture baggage
because michelle yo is a singular person
in the world there is no other actor who
can do what she does and can do all of
the things that she had she can do and
has been doing it for 40 years
you know and if you've been a fan like
you've seen her in super cop you've seen
her in hero trio you've seen her for
40 years crouching tiger you know and
and being able to do like high drama and
deep martial arts and and all of that
stuff
there's there's nobody else who could
pull that off and sort of to convince
her
by offering her a thing that she never
thought she'd get there's this great
online video
you know an interview with her around
the time the movie is first released
where she starts to cry
talking about the fact that she never
thought i saw that she would get like
nobody has ever seen all of me
and thought that i could do all of these
things and then i got this script and it
was the thing i've been waiting my whole
career for it was a moving interview she
does she just breaks down crying talking
about getting this role and you know
[ __ ] actors
sometimes they'll cry at the drop of a
hat if they watch a good episode of the
flash an actor will [ __ ] cry
but this was insanely sincere somebody
who like thought
that their
that the industry felt their best work
was behind them yeah and she was
incredibly moved by these two filmmakers
who were like here here's something that
only you can do
and jackie chan but we want you to do it
and let's go forward yeah i can i could
see that like talk about feeling seen
yeah you know what i'm saying like i'm
sure she didn't feel like my best works
behind me she feels like look [ __ ]
they're good the best work could be
right around the corner and there's no
way she doesn't get nominated for an
award it should win all the things and
for
kihuikuan
to get called off the bench
like here's a dude who 30 years ago was
like you know what i don't think
hollywood has anything for me anymore
they just want me to play the precocious
asian kid who gets into trouble i'm
pretty sure there's a revenge of the
nerd sequel down the pike for me that i
don't want to do so i'm just going to
back away and find another life to live
right and then the daniel st by me like
hey man we think this is for you
and he's amazing he's fantastic like he
is he also like fights in the he's
jackie chan and
fat and tony lung and a little bit
harrison ford and a little bit like
the the the
kind of besmirched put upon husband ben
stiller he and he does that softer side
plays insanely well yeah because he does
have a
a role
like he's a nice guy but he is the one
flirting with divorce and you could
easily hate that guy particularly
because you love michelle yo but he
plays it in such a way that you're not
like oh this [ __ ] guy this home
record like he also is put upon yeah
like i cannot say enough about this
movie but i don't want to say any more
about this movie because the more you
say
the less you experience cold going in
did you ever see a trailer because i
don't know how the [ __ ] they could have
sold this movie i did and it was it they
sold it a bit like the matrix
you know where like it's she's just a
woman who's living her life and suddenly
you know fate calls for her and then she
starts downloading kung fu and doing
cool [ __ ]
i can see that that's a way to sell it
but it's not that at all no there's a
fantastic ratatouille joke in the movie
a running joke raccoon yeah raccoony
um it's worth your time and effort kids
to seek out
everything everywhere all at once
special special little feature go see it
you can tell from these cats
yeah
um all right we haven't even started the
news so let's start the news we'll start
the news um in obvious news of the week
they're making a sequel to the batman
what
i thought that movie flopped you know i
mean it turns out if you make it i don't
know why they waited till cinecom this
is such a joke they're like uh well we
don't know if we're gonna do it we're
gonna figure out and look and see and
then cinecom's like the batman tarou
yeah a lot of pattinson's coming back
patins is coming back matt reeves is
coming back but in in vegas this week is
an event called cinemacon which is where
all of the studios gather all of the
owners of theaters in america get them
psyched for what parade their wares
here's what's coming down the pike for
the next year and so they're announcing
things they're getting first looks on
things which sadly rarely make it to the
public out of cinemacon like they showed
a willy wonka trailer today for a movie
that's not coming out for the one with
timothy yeah charlemage wonka you know
what's [ __ ] i just realized if like
if we wanted to be in on this
information all we have to do is own a
movie theater
because then we they let us go to this
[ __ ] and then we can [ __ ] see this
[ __ ] early then come on to fat man
beyond and be like spoilers
i mean and honestly
we could probably cover it as press
because did they let the press go to
cinecom mm-hmm
one year we'll have to have moxie
it sounds more fun to own a movie thing
i mean yeah
but there's got to be a way in man i
want to see this [ __ ]
i'm telling you next year we'll have to
see if we can register this bam oh banff
fans here ladies and gentlemen i think
the arc lights open do we want to just
cool our money and buy the arclight that
place seems expensive
[Music]
they sell all them high-end snacks those
bougie snacks might be a little too rich
for my blood
um what else we got um so yes they're
making the batman ii
amen
uh i hear did somebody just say ah
where was that fair
that's
i like you yeah
that's brazen ballsy honesty well done
look they say they might be going for uh
and to be fair for the internet that's
not me going ah that's her
yes
[ __ ] i don't need people in chat
going did he say [ __ ] uh [ __ ] mr
yoga hosers hey
you um i might be uh i don't know where
people are getting this but everyone
keeps going mr freeze i guess matt
reeves did some interview where he's
like yeah i guess i could make mr freeze
work
or something like that i'm still fingers
crossed for [ __ ] egghead i so badly
want to see nicholas nicholas play why
not let him play him in the opening five
minutes kill the guy off that'd be
amazing what a great way to open the
batman too like not only did they do
egghead they [ __ ] killed him right in
the beginning
they cracked his egg head they threw him
off a roof and they scrambled that [ __ ]
humpty dumpty fell down
um all right what's next well you know
at cinemacon they showed a picture for
this barbie movie the first picture of
margot robbie roby robbie
robbie uh dressed up uh up like barbie
they haven't shown ryan gosling as ken
yet
um but they're playing barbie and ken i
think this movie looks [ __ ]
phenomenal greta gerwig's directon he's
got a bigger cast than the muppet movie
all all famous people so it looks like
it could be fun man i'm getting lego
move lego movie vibes right yeah even
though i've only seen a picture
all right i'm thinking i'll hold you to
that i think they cracked the code as i
sit there in the theater grumbling
angrily as a kevin said lego movie vibes
[ __ ] you kevin between her and [ __ ]
ryan gosling they don't have to call it
the barbie movie they could call it the
white white movie
very very
fair kids
also out of uh cinemacon we are getting
uh venom three
what a shock i know because again
because the other two didn't make any
money so naturally yeah good i'm glad
they announced that i saw sony announced
a bunch of things the other day they
they also announced ghostbusters after
life 2. oh i didn't see that or at least
a follow-up to afterlife whatever
they're going to call is that gonna be
jason reitman again um it seems as if it
is going to be good and it's a great job
of the last one it's a little surprising
only because the i mean granted we were
in a pandemic until nothing did
amazingly well oh the business-wise yeah
because it only made 200 million dollars
worldwide which doesn't automatically
trigger what a paltry sub no generally
you're right generally 200 million
doesn't like make people go let's make a
sequel but
i think
that had more to do with the franchi
with the pandemic not the franchise
itself and you know i think they feel
like they righted their ship after
having taken so much [ __ ] for the last
time they did a movie so now they'll
i it makes sense that they do it again
um i mean look it makes sense they do it
every other [ __ ] year why not man as
long as you get the script right
go nuts um are you familiar with a
spider-man character named el muerto
um no but that's because he was only in
two comic books ever yes
only in two issues of spider-man if that
ever he's getting a movie i saw that man
um boy sony going nuts with all these
they're like morbius was so great let's
make another one
yeah man and so bad bunny has been cast
he's a singer he is a he is a very
popular reggaeton artist he was on snl
once i saw him
oh right on yeah i was just there i know
i figured funny they didn't mention him
to me i'm surprised he's not plastered
all over the airport the way rihanna is
in barbados right
um so yes they're making an el muerto
movie
i don't know why he's a wrestler right
he's dressed like a wrestler essentially
he looks like bane he's got a mask and
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
um i mean it seems like they got a you
know rich tapestry characters there uh
why they're starting with el muerto
it's up to them but i mean like i i'm of
two minds the first mine is i'm not
particularly enthused at the way sony is
building out their
kevin feigless marvel spider-man
universe because i haven't liked very
many of those movies other than into the
spider-verse right which really stands
apart it really does um so like i think
this will probably be bad because
none of these have been good
but i also think wait wait wait you're
basing your decision on evidence what
the [ __ ]
but i also think it's a brilliant
business decision because bad bunny is
like one of the top five touring artists
in the world smart and you know
catering to the latinx audience
nobody ever went broke doing such smart
so like yeah let's make the first marvel
sony spider-man movie featuring a latino
lead
and let's make all of the money
hopefully it's good nobody wants a bad
movie and nobody wants you know a a a
first of a thing to be bad at the thing
so like yeah i'm i'll see it because of
course i'll see it i saw [ __ ] morbius
clearly we'll see anything
you you have my laziest money sony
um but it i i don't know
it's uh
i i mean maybe somebody maybe it's
because they're doing the into the
spider verse and they're like that's his
thing but like
in a world where you're not gonna make
peter parker spider-man which is all
anybody wants the only other thing they
want is miles morales spider-man so like
why not live-action that before you get
to
to madame webb albuerto
like
even craven it just feels like
you want to print money again they test
drove this character into the
spider-verse and everybody loved them so
it's like do your live action version
man so i'm sure they're getting to it
i'm sure there's a reason they're
waiting yeah you know and if it if i had
to guess i would also guess that maybe
kevin feige and big marvel have plans
for miles morales you think so
that would make me very happy man i like
what they do with all their [ __ ] i like
watching kevin feige play with his toys
it's fun
it doesn't make me want to do it i'm
never like ooh let me play i'm content
to just cuck it out and be like you play
with that [ __ ]
i'm gonna put my [ __ ] hat on and i'm
gonna watch you play yes
uh speaking of spiderman i'm talking
about my stance
your buffalo stance [ __ ] hat
remembered
um
sucker
wow thank you well done never left my
ipod a little nina cherry every night
rolls up on you know she her brother was
also a singer is that buckeye cherry
eagle eye he's the one that did i think
it's not that buck is that a brother or
cousin
cherry i believe that's a porn star
he did he said what was his song
tonight what are the chances that two
family members
like break huge would you like to meet
the jacksons
i guess you're right chances are
look at all these [ __ ] checks i
smoked the jacksons away for some reason
and yet the osmonds are still there
still hanging out what else you got um
one last spider-man related story um the
into the spider-verse sequel is moving
out of 2022. [ __ ]
damn it now i have to live another
goddamn year yes
all right i'll do it just to see this
[ __ ] movie but yeah it's moving why
are they moving it is there another
covet coming we don't know about it
there's there's always going to be
others
um
it's it hasn't been stated why yet but a
few moves like that yeah it seems like
they know something we don't
where they're picking up on like no this
shit's going to be cyclical now so right
people aren't going to be able to go to
movie theaters i mean nobody gave a [ __ ]
about
kova during no way home
i met three people who were like i got
sick going to no way home and i don't
regret it at all
oh america
yes they were all actually two were
canadians so [ __ ] that
ah north america north america not
americanos um so yes it's moving from
october 7th of this year to june 2nd of
next year
um [ __ ] yeah but they then they also
clearly are shuffling the sequel to that
which is now spider-man beyond the
spider-verse
that's the the part two that's part two
is coming in uh march 29 2024
and that seems so far away
uh the fan and me when was it supposed
to come um this october the fan in me is
sad it's moving the guy who has to
release a movie himself this fall not
too bad yeah not too bad to see it go
make room for clerks three my friend
um
here's a story that you will not care
about but i was watching with very keen
attention okay
um
fast and the furious 10
now dubbed fast x
and not fast 10 your seat belts which is
what it should have been called
that's good see it's sitting right
[ __ ] there yeah universal that is
good
um lost his director uh just as justin
lin
in production
backed out of the movie
they already started shooting yeah well
that's not backing out that's called
quitting i believe
backing out is when you're like ah you
guys do this without me but he's like i
have the job and i don't want it yeah
the verbiage they use is uh justin lynn
is stepping down as director of the next
installment when he backed out
and then he [ __ ] floored it and he
jumped through a building into a blimp i
gotta go
like that guy made a hell of an exit
but yes the citing the the oft-used and
ill-defined creative differences sounds
like i hate vin diesel
not me but justin lynn probably possibly
plays
you know but who else is in that cast
i don't watch the movies you don't let's
see who's problematic is the girl
from the faculty still jordana brewster
she's still in it um that's where she
went to those movies yeah all right so
she's not problematic i never hear [ __ ]
about her no tyrese is he problematic
i think
he's a lot of things
but he's like why are you just trying to
stifle a laugh like he's tyrese and so
he's but nothing he can't shut a movie
down or delay production i don't think
tyrese is getting in the way of anything
who else is lucky to be there
uh ludacris
yeah ludacris based similarly like are
you gonna feed me lunch then luna's
gonna be there luda
who else uh
used to be the rock not the rock anymore
yeah which is weird because i thought it
was all about family but
so it sounds like there's one
michelle rodriguez she doesn't sound
problematic at all um no i think she's
again like happy to be there happy to
keep getting those [ __ ] checks so
justin lynn probably
probably
jason momoa
okay
he's the villain in this one yeah but
he's the new guy so i can't imagine he
shows up to set and he's like look how
big an [ __ ] i could be
and he's a nice guy like by all reports
i met him in real life he was nice but
on the aquaman set people really like
him
but vin diesel like made the rock mad
how do you make the rock mad so if if
you if you piss off the rock to the
point where he's like we're going to
start a whole other franchise so i don't
have to deal with this person i guess
maybe justin lin might have hit the same
wall
entirely possibly all speculation
especially given that justin lin is
responsible for something like seven
billion dollars for universal having
directed five of these movies yeah and
he's the one that turned it around right
like this was a franchise that started
as one thing and
rooted in reality and then was he did he
start with tokyo drift he started with
tokyo drift and then he did the fourth
one fifth one sixth one and then he took
a break for seven and eight and then
came back for nine
and they've all made upwards of
a billion dollars
the story behind the story though is
just it's the same old stories the same
as ever was in hollywood um no one is
more powerful than a movie star
because you're talking about a guy who
has made that studio
billions of dollars
and at the end of the day the studio is
going to let them walk away because
they're like yeah but we got somebody
else we got to keep happy if that's the
reason again i don't know how to watch
these movies but yeah
people seem to have issue with him all
the time and the the tricky thing is
which horse you're gonna bet on right
it's like i got vin diesel who's the
star of these movies yeah we got to make
one more and we know it's the last one
is it the last one is the last one
why
um
if i had to guess it's because
i'm not saying why because i want more
but like if you're printing money why
ever stop they could get up to like fast
28.
okay good jaw's 29. if you get into 10
you got to go to 69. that's the next
stop
um but yeah
for family
then he dies in space
there already been this space they've
been to space around here we went to
space already i was [ __ ] around oh
jesus because that's all that's left is
multi multi-space like
inter-dimensional travel i mean i think
what they're what i'm hoping they do at
some point is they go back to jurassic
times
cars versus dinosaurs cadillacs and
dinosaurs i might [ __ ] be into that
that's when they'll get me that's when
i'm like you have my attention yeah
jurassic park
if they ever fight batman then i'll
watch that movie
i still haven't watched it faster or
furious movie i know well we still have
to do our fast and by curious podcast
i'm holding fastback what a great time
i'm holding out until universal pays us
to do it
how do we get these tubby bastards to
watch this thing like for some reason we
really need silent bob to watch these
movies
uh
in other news um i don't know if you
guys knew that they were making a sequel
to bright
do you remember that movie that was on
netflix the max landis wrote that's
excellent will smith set in the world of
series
where fairies and orcs and goblins were
living side by side with humanity in l.a
essentially the live-action version of
that disney cartoon from the beginning
of the pandemic
what was it called
onward yes onward yeah
um yeah they were making a sequel to
that for reasons that escaped me is he
gonna be in it or no will smith um
they've now decided to not make the
sequel to this
oh that's a real [ __ ] slap in the
face
yes
my dad joke in the evening ladies and
gentlemen thank you uh i think you can
hit the showers kid thank you i'm gonna
get better than that good night
everybody uh so wait they're not making
it now uh were they making it with him
they were making it with him um
yet another franchise he was gonna have
indeed uh apparently according to
reports the cancellation is unrelated to
the incident
sounds plausible sure
uh
and then netflix is also
they they made a spin-off animated
series called bright samurai soul that
was supposed to come out in 2021
although it's unclear when that will
debut if at all
so yeah that's happening or not
happening
um i think this broke around the same
time the news that netflix has for the
first time in its uh existence
lost subscribers they lost 200 000
subscribers um all of them said
you killed he-man you piece of [ __ ] and
they
no they lost yeah for the first time
they lost some subscribers but not even
like didn't hemorrhage millions they
hemorrhaged like 200 000 but that's in a
world where you got disney plus [ __ ]
hbo max like they had
they had the playing fields themselves
for so long but now it's you know there
are other
places that are putting up [ __ ]
strong programming man hbo max is
spending as much money as netflix was
spending back in the day and they've got
all the ip as well so it's like they
could do [ __ ] like oh we're making a
batgirl movie and we're putting it on
hbo max
yeah i mean netflix's entire business
was built on scale
scale and growth
whereas apple can spend twice the money
that netflix can but it only ever seems
that there's one apple show at a time
yes you know or at least one that's
catching on right now it's going to be
severance month and then it's going to
be less a month and then it's going to
be this month and then there's shows
they do that you don't really hear much
about there's that will ferrell
and paul rudd show like yeah
or something that i thought was gonna
break the internet but nobody's really
talking about it
um so yeah ted lasso is their big
[ __ ] it's the one that and now they
just got the academy award for uh what
was the coda for coda
um but yeah they don't have to worry
about like
you know and netflix making hits they're
just like we're just gonna make tv
because we have all the money yeah and
they don't have to worry about it being
their revenue stream which is where
[ __ ] apple the same way amazon is
like yeah we could give a [ __ ] if
anybody watches lord of the rings we'd
like them to we don't need them to yeah
because we just want to bring you to the
site so you buy more paper towels
i mean not even like amazon makes i
think it's something like 60 of their
money off of the amazon web services off
of the cloud
like is that right yeah like
netflix runs on amazon servers oh [ __ ]
is that right yeah
wow as does the pentagon
wow
so like sobering thought
in it though so like it doesn't matter
to them like yeah we'll make that four
billion dollars back
in a month and a half of leasing server
space to the government geez so it's
true when you go pitch at amazon
um i don't know if it's still the way
but like
you
you know every place you go you got to
show your license and they give you a
[ __ ] pass to get in but they have
these high security doors and [ __ ] and
dudes there who are armed and i remember
the first time i was like well i was
awfully mo was bezos worried we're going
to [ __ ] steal paper towels
and though like the government servers
are on floors four and five and i was
like what do you mean the government
servers that like your government
and i was like is mixing with amazon
all right
they've got a lot of the a lot of cloud
space up there yeah
um and our final story of the evening
[ __ ] is uh
is alleged [ __ ] ezra miller
holy [ __ ] man
has now been arrested in hawaii again
this was like last week
unless there's a news story this is last
week this was last week
after an incident a private residence he
was arrested on uh on april 19th they
sorry they they were arrested they were
bad i think i said
um yeah they they need some help
apparently um or
maybe they need to never drink again but
that's two franchises for warner
brothers
that they're in and and both of them are
family
yeah franchises yeah like if you were
gonna behave this way and you were you
know only promote movies like we need to
talk about kevin very on brand and [ __ ]
but he's doing family films [ __ ]
harry potter movies [ __ ]
just as he's the flash for god's sakes
yeah grant well yes i agree grant gustin
we all love
yeah as the true the one true flash i
keep hoping that that uh warner brothers
spends all the money in the world to put
christopher plummer into the flash to
put grant gustin into the flash that'd
be amazing let's copy paste this dude
right in there what do they do man do
you think they're just like please
leave hawaii man
why are you there yeah we gotta release
a movie soon and [ __ ] when's that movie
come out uh flash hell if i know man
i i i i weighed you they they they
i wager that they will push that movie a
little bit because if if they keep on
[ __ ] around in hawaii and keep
doing dumb [ __ ] every other month
like when when do we get a chance to
sell a movie without you already being
in the news as a felon yeah it's tough
it's not even like remember how
they like threatened the clan some weird
like obscure chapter of the clan and
everyone was like go flash like [ __ ] it
well done
nobody nobody liking this nobody's like
yeah whip chairs at people it just makes
no sense and it just i mean i don't know
the dude that
i don't know them from adam but
it feels like
or eve
but it feels like they have a
substance thing
they they have a seems like booze is
always involved when
they get in trouble it seems like
there's a litany of things in the speed
force that are haranguing yes that poor
person yeah so and i remember hearing
that there was a high top-level meeting
at warner brothers
on how we deal with the ezra miller
situation i'm sure they got in the
office and they were like [ __ ]
all right meeting adjourned
i mean i guess you know like what are we
gonna do we already shot the [ __ ]
movie
um well
we'll keep an eye on that situation
but there have been enough incidences
now that you could make a graphic for
ezra miller watch or something like that
it's kind of a shame
it is
speaking of a shame
let's talk about our last sponsor
and with that segway ladies and
gentlemen uh that's it for the news
that's it for the news there it is kids
we did the news man give it up for mark
you found the news
did um
i i don't believe we've talked about
love and thunder have we oh we have not
but you're forgetting your place in this
show you come in when you say bam there
you go give it up for banff man
everybody
um
they put up the thor loving thunder
trailer and it was absolutely wonderful
um i like uh very much taika waititi's
rendition of uh thor
and chris hemsworth continues to be
both insanely easy to look at
and
funny and warm and [ __ ] wonderful
he's such a gift that guy um
but you know seeing
jane foster at the end of the [ __ ]
trailer
catch the hammer was pretty damn
pretty damn cool pretty neat
i just love that moment where
where i think
peter quill is telling him some story
he's like well you know if you just love
somebody you just gotta kind of look him
in the eye and tell him and then she's
doing this [ __ ]
yeah
nothing i just have something in my eye
um and they show us that like he works
out gets rid of the weight and
i look forward to it man and they
haven't even shown us [ __ ] christian
bell yet we don't know what gore the god
butcher even looks like i hope they keep
it hidden
like i want to be surprised by it i saw
a picture of an action figure and
it just looked like christian bale
he's been in action figures before yeah
truly
um all right man so is that all you got
that's it i saw a great meme though that
was uh
you know they have those memes it's like
uh anakin and padme
and yes anakin goes
uh my padme you've you've grown and it's
her with the hammer and the
biceps
i just love that nice you got your star
wars in my thor yeah
um that's all the news we got then
that's all the news there it is man give
it up for mark you found you the news
uh so yes our final sponsor for the
evening before we dive into the sponsor
how's the chat been
uh chat's been good a lot of talk about
morbius for whatever reason
because it's morbius month it's
monthlies yeah i mean basically yeah
they're just
um what kind of talk like what the [ __ ]
it seems like every week in chat there's
a it's like the fat man beyond chat gets
together without us and comes up with a
theme and has a show
it has a show like last show it was milk
bags
like they were talking about
milk and milk bags in canada and this
week is yeah this week is morbius it's
just like did you see the
the cameo of morbius in the latest
moonlight and just and they're just
making [ __ ] up they're like did you see
that
morbius
four just got cancelled but two and
three are still on like they're just
vegans and there's like ten people who
just keep going
it's like a show within the show
um
as long as they're entertained and if
it's not coming from us and they're
coming from each other i'm totally okay
with that
um all right new uh sponsor last one who
is it the good folks at chili sleep
chili sleep the mattress
yes i literally did this did you [ __ ]
cool it's cool
yes look what you did it is absolutely
cool as a man who uh generates a lot of
body heat who sleeps next to a woman who
has the spine of a [ __ ] cylon she's
always hot
and then uh [ __ ] dog the [ __ ]
doctrine sleeps between us and that's a
little [ __ ] three bar fire fire
generator i sweat every morning i wake
up and i have to change my [ __ ] top i
put this thing on
did not sweat it all it was nice it was
like sleeping in an air conditioning
room it was nice
it's like you're always on the other
side of the pillow that's is that their
tag phrase because it should be their
their tagline it is not well it's a
great [ __ ] line
it's all yours chili's take that man it
is it's all chilly sleep it's like
you're always sleeping on the cool side
of the pillow indeed tell them what it
does
science tells us the best way to achieve
and maintain consistent deep sleep is by
lowering core body temperature
temperature controlled sleep repairs
muscle after hard day's work and
improves cognitive function so you can
always start your day feeling sharp and
alert
chili sleeps makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that help you
improve your entire well-being they make
the uhler and cube sleep systems
hydropower temperature-controlled
matches toppers that fit over your
existing matches to provide your ideal
sleep temperature it wasn't hard at all
it wasn't even difficult to set up it
wasn't like [ __ ] it was going to take an
hour bam done for reals threw a [ __ ]
sheet on was ready to go told my wife
get on the bed
she was like oh no
i was like it ain't that we're just
going to be cold together
i don't got my hat on so don't worry
i don't have my hat on
um chilly sleep man chilly sleep where
do they go to look up info head over to
chilisleep.com fat man that's c-h-i-l-i
sleep dot com slash fat man to learn
more and save 30 off the purchase of any
new cube or sleep system the offer is
available exclusively for fat man beyond
listeners and only for a limited time
that's chile c-h-i-l-i sleep dot com fat
man to take advantage of our exclusive
discount and wake up refreshed every day
absolutely works i'm here to tell you it
works man give us a shot chilly sleep
kids give it up for the good folks at
chili slate
sponsors
of fat man beyond
uh next step kids you know we're gonna
do the fun part of the show that's the q
and a part of the show before they do
this children jump up to the mic real
quick uh where jc is
uh to tell people about this bad boy
this is i'm going that way let's go to
this camera andrew this is the here jc
take this bad boy up to the as close to
the camera as you can without it getting
fuzzy
it's good there i mean it's tiny there
oh it gets dark yeah
it's uh a guru askew man uh give the
camera to choker this is the artist give
it up for children everybody
a couple months ago he put out a red
version of guru sku it's a version of me
that's got like three hands and one's
holding the movie one's holding a
director's uh
uh was that bullhorn
microphone for the podcasters lightsaber
there's a clerk script long saber and a
one hand is the joint right is the j
joint
oh he's got it it's right there
so the red one came out a few months ago
this one is like the weed edition and
it's got like that moss man skin to it
yeah it's flocked uh it came out on 420
it came out on 420. what is it called
what's the word flocked flocked blocked
have you ever heard that like not in
polite like panthor panthor is flocked
it does it feels like [ __ ] panthord
go flock yourself go block yourself
um
the uh where can they get it they can
get it at sideshow they can get at
scishowcollectibles.com on really
industries or at jsonbob.combob.com
they got them signed i signed a bunch of
these today
[ __ ] gorgeous piece man
um and then there's one more so he's got
the red bull in his hands this one is
the what are you calling it 420. uh the
dope
the dope edition that's funny and then
there's one more to come and that's like
the black and white that's the clerk's
edition that's very very cool man um
beautiful [ __ ] piece we've sold them
at the secret stash uh back east we sell
them online and stuff and we'll be
selling these signed last time i signed
the red box
instead of signing the figure and a
bunch of people were like [ __ ] you sign
the figure so this time around i'm
signing the backs on all the figures and
stuff that's why that's why i took it
out it would make your life easier you
want me to do gold for sure yeah yeah go
for it yeah and if it and if it doesn't
work we can try it out with something
else later so it's done and done
that's mine it is a
beautiful
piece man and my wife loves it she's
like finally they did you cute
one more time folks there he is
put him over here thank you
um all right jc take back that mic and
let's uh find out what people want to
know we got some [ __ ] to give away
indeed where's the hey andrew where's
that thing remember
it's in the well to my right you're
absolutely right it is boom um okay this
was a very cool thing that when we went
to see the batman
uh claire our friend claire bateman king
she's the one that got us
seats upstairs like at the at the tcl
chinese theater private booth we got to
watch the movie uh at the end they gave
away these backpacks uh imax backpack
and inside it's full of stuff it's got
like a thermos it's got like a computer
bag it's got an imax hat so
this is one of the prizes tonight
the other
uh one of the prizes uh is
i brought in two cans of
soda pop from funko soda it's a silent
bob a little soda pop it looks like it's
a drink
but you open up the can and it's got a
little a little action figure in action
figure inside
so we've got that
uh first place second or whoever gets up
first can make their pick but we also
have in addition to that
copies of mark's heralded book which you
probably saw on [ __ ] seth meyers
adora and the distance if you haven't
read it read it right now
three lucky people
will be leaving here tonight with their
own copy did you sign it i will he will
sign it for you as well
um so those are prizes we didn't brett
didn't come right deegan's not here i
think he's at cinemacon he went to
cinemacon
he's seeing all the cool [ __ ] yeah he
texted me he's like
something can you come and get tickets
and i was like i can't get there to get
tickets so he's so sweet um so no
tickets this week but um
[ __ ] man i bet you he saw some cool [ __ ]
i bet you did he sees everything early
like he's he's i believe he's already
seen doctor strange
because they have to for the 40x process
and stuff son of a [ __ ] um okay uh so
you got uh some comics and you got a bag
and you got uh two funko soda pops
if
your question's good enough and let's be
honest we've never judged anyone's
question
as being so bad that like you don't
deserve a [ __ ] prize [ __ ] off so if
you get asked if you ask a question
you're going to walk away with some
school cool [ __ ] um
thanks to the good folks at uh dark
horse
comics
i thought you were like giving these
away i was like i think they belong to
somebody
um i'm giving [ __ ] away yeah like and
who wants some of this [ __ ] what about
you jc what do we got um well first off
so the chat told me the it seems as
though whatever the topic for the night
is
they come up with it's the people who
show up
at like 7 30 and hang out in the chat
room until we start right they
come up with something and that's their
theme for the night
so matt in chat was like
well the
the preview image was you guys as
morbius so
we we needed to do something for 30
minutes while we waited for the show to
start
so that's i guess it came all morpheus
machines yeah i guess that's what
happens uh beautiful piece of artwork
this week uh put together of course by
uh the great dark nate gonzalez give it
up for him he's not here though no
missed out this week i wonder if the
chat has thought about masturbation
because that would easily fill half an
hour
just saying guys you masturbate for half
an hour i'm like done in two minutes
i love myself
i loathe myself i just want to get it
over with fast
move on
do it deus mount do it slowly yeah
really look at you you're like i need to
spend quality time with myself
for me it's about quantity not quality
all right first question of the evening
who do we have eric potter who eric give
it up for eric
got one of them cool movies jerseys i
see
they only made 420 of them what can we
do for eric all right guys so my
question is if you were given the
opportunity to take over the dceu to
create your own smith verse or bernard
inverse which hero would you start with
and what steps would you take to ensure
cinematic success what a great question
if it's dc
i mean i know i should be doing like
look if
if i'm a smart business person
and they give me the dc universe to play
with first thing i do is superman
because there's your jesus you get that
right everything else will be [ __ ]
easy this is the first
superhero the [ __ ] blueprint the
prototype this is a character that like
they should be making more movies of
than batman because he's a character
that stands for like [ __ ] hope and
stuff like that so i think you get that
right i'm not saying i would do the best
version of superman no not at all but
i would try like [ __ ] to get that right
because once you nail that i think
everything else is kind of [ __ ] easy
superman has a lot of elements that are
you know more challenging than batman we
all love batman because he's like i can
be batman you can be batman he's a rich
guy with a [ __ ] car and he's real emo
so
superman gives you something to aspire
to something you can't really be right
the way that some the religious people
the spiritual look to jesus they'll
never be jesus but like look at him he's
this great model savior same thing with
uh superman you know superman just got a
better outfit than jesus and uh you
could tell a lot more stories because
superman got way more bad guys than
jesus jesus got like pontius pilate
superman got like everybody in the dcu
um so if i was a smart businessman i'd
begin with superman and get that right
but knowing me i'd probably try to make
the question instead
and people would be like what a mistake
it would be like remember when universal
was like we're starting the dark monster
universe [ __ ] look at all these
famous people first up is the mummy with
tom cruise and then two weeks later like
we're done
and i think it would be that way if i
began my dc eu with like the question
they'd be like what like this is bleak
there's you could have done anything you
could have nailed green land not [ __ ]
them but you could have nailed green
lantern as a movie but instead or i
could have done that too but instead you
went with the question so i think i get
ridiculed superman would be the one i
would kind of go for arrow makes a lot
of sense too
yeah but they made that show and then
you'd be letting people down right if
you don't make a movie as good as the
show that they watched for six years
then you're a [ __ ] idiot who ruined
it so nobody's touched the question yet
so even if i [ __ ] it up nobody'll be
like chris nolan did it better because
nobody's done it yet at all so i'd be
i'd be tempted to make the question but
smart business would make
would get superman right and and nail
that and then build the rest of the
universe however
green lantern's possibility too because
that's very magical if you get that
[ __ ] right like you could make
guardians the galaxy in dc and stuff um
but i think i think superman if i was
being a smart business person
uh
the question if i was being me over to
you and that's for dc that's for dc
marvel i wouldn't do anything they're
doing everything [ __ ] right they need
no help for me whatsoever
they got a kevin in charge there and
he's [ __ ] brilliant so they need no
help from this kevin um i think i might
start with uh the sandman
because for me the sandman is the story
that lets you do every other story
like if you can get the dream lord right
if you can get that framework right then
you get to dip in and out of all these
movies and you get to depend on all
these characters and you can do
superheroes you can do magic you can do
gods and monsters you can do greek
mythology you can do every [ __ ] thing
under the sun
with that being your overarching
mythology
um
and then you get to do your superman
movie you get to do your question moving
you get to do batman because all of
these are dreams of somebody
everybody's having these nightmares or
these hopes of these ones
um failing that because sandman is a
hard sell
um you know
[ __ ] netflix is gonna be selling it
soon and as a movie in some quarters i
imagine it would be a little difficult
and the business people would be like
really this one first yeah but i think
wonder woman is to your point like
getting superman right if you get wonder
woman right
then that that a tells you the totality
of this universe and it gives you gods
and it gives you heroes and it gives you
all of the things you're looking for
um then you because doing one of the
trinity feels like it makes sense
but batman and i love batman the show is
named after [ __ ] batman titular
character we all adore him but he's
tough to build a universe around because
he's such a [ __ ] loner you know what
i'm saying like superman is like i'm
friends with everybody i need another
super person and now we're super friends
but batman is just like [ __ ] off i work
alone you know so it's fun but like it
doesn't allow you to build the universe
you can start the bet family you know
you could start the bat family and even
there you know
branch off
he's he's he's a solo flyer you know to
me he always works best i'm not saying
he don't work with robin or nightwing or
any of that or batgirl no of course but
the character is a dark grim avenger and
and you know having those other
characters around to keep them from
going off the deep end
that's cool but
those movies
are at their best when he's just him by
himself
doing his thing and most batman stories
i feel function best that way as well um
and again i don't want to get beat up in
[ __ ] chats people like [ __ ] you
batman rules of course i love batman but
in this world where it's like i gotta
make the dc eu
superman is the well i mean which they
did zack snyder did that exact thing he
first went in he was like let's get
superman and then all right let's bring
him batman let's bring in wonder woman
let's bring in
aquaman
um you go and i went uh you went then i
went and then but i do think that
there's there's a tony stark style throw
that you could do with batman i was
thinking that too because like the
character who only works alone
to the guy who despite his best
intentions and efforts builds a family
you know and so you end the the bruce
wayne story with him surrounded by
people that he loves and who love him
back even though but after a lot of
movies right yeah the same way we went
10 years before tony stark became the
guy who would sacrifice himself or
anybody oh [ __ ] you talking about doing
like a long con game with batman like
over the course that's amazing the long
throw and so you end with the dark
knight returns and you end him
surrounded by
the people that he helped form and the
heroes that he helped create i like that
i want to watch you know what take my
money i want to see your movies
it's a lot of movies it's a lot of
movies um great question
and it yielded some uh wonderful answers
give it up for him ladies and gentlemen
backpacker soda can
take the backpack and
slip that fine comic book in there all
right jc where are we going next uh
christopher ramsey chris get up here man
give it up for chris
mr ramsay how are you good how are you
doing fabulous awesome all right so the
first question it's a two-parter but the
same uh theme
mark other than jay and silent bill
who from the usq cinematic universe best
fits into the world of adora and the
distance wow what a great question um
i uh i wanted to say
god
but not quite
um i think i think loki though
matt damon not to be confused with tom
hiddleston yoki loki yeah i think
who was also the matt damon loki that's
true he did that too
but yeah i think i think loki i think
loki
has a character who wants what he can't
have um i think there's something about
the the
a person's reach should exceed their
grasp of what to heaven for and so i
think that in a book like adora in that
world it's all about wanting something
and being kept from it
and so i feel like loki
as a misunderstood protagonist in
somebody else's story might fit pretty
well in there love it nice
and kevin um who would you cast in your
cinematic version of adora in the
distance
can we put rosario in a
in a youthifying can we get 25 years out
of rosarito can we do that rick and
morty thing
rebuild the morty
um
yeah i mean because she's wonderful how
old is dora
10.
can we go back in time sure
young raven simone from the cosby show
oh
everybody loves her adorable
now that's predicated on you know
controlling time and space i mean which
we can't but
probably best with a newcomer right like
in terms of playing the league
um
but if i was casting a real thing
like if i was casting as a movie and
stuff well i i don't want to spoil it
but you eventually get to a place in the
story
where we make a jump
i could easily cast
the people when we make the jump on the
other side yeah i'm standing next to one
of them right now so
i'd be like why don't you do it um but
yeah i'm no actor
well you were no
[ __ ]
comedian either when we started but i
saw a very funny man on seth myers the
other night so
it's surprising what you could be
i know if only somebody would give me
some lines
that's true
um good uh good question good answers
man give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen chris
take a can of soda
take dora well done my friend well done
there you go all right jc what do we got
lastly last question all right uh
spencer bell
spence get up here give it up
before we dive in who who dropped off
the dgc stuff the directors go canada
what is that all about it's adorable
[ __ ] hey
ride the [ __ ] out
you were on the flash pilot yeah
[ __ ] a yeah
the [ __ ] man how was that night shoots
everything right uh yeah
we have now just taken a strike vote yes
we have a straight mandate um
sorry strike mandate um talking about
the dgc the director
director's guild of canada uh we are the
counterparts to the director's guild of
america right
so we deal with the same producers
producers representatives for
negotiating and what has just recently
happened
is well we've been without a contract
for over a year right
and
now we had for the first time ever in
canadian history
we took a strike vote and had a 92.2
percent
uh strike vote mandate
and then as of april 25th at 5 25 p.m or
something like that uh i i've been here
for like a week now but we uh just have
a
an email that said our
union the director's guild of canada has
now said we have a strike mandate so we
are now trying to get so that we have
uh safety respect
uh and
equality with
the other guilds throughout
north america
and yeah well you you you've been to
vancouver i've been there shows man and
they're lovely i love them but they do
long hours oh hell yeah [ __ ] hours
and
when you're doing superhero stuff tends
to play best at night you do a lot of
night shoots and people aren't their
most crisp or best at night so you know
i i never i i saw one
mini
accident that was not you know through
any sort of
negligence or anything it was just a
mishap whenever you do stunts there's
always a good chance
something could happen and i saw like
somebody
get pulled time was off and stuff and
you know we were in the middle of the
night and at that point i'm not i'm i'm
not telling this story and making myself
the hero but after that injury happened
i was like and it wasn't bad it wasn't
like we gotta put a person in a [ __ ]
ambulance but once i saw somebody kind
of get even quasi hurt i was like we're
done for the night and they're like we
got four more things to shoot i'm like
[ __ ] man like somebody
just got [ __ ] hurt we gotta stop i
can't even say it was all about like
everyone else it was like two in the
morning i was like [ __ ] this is a
great reason to go home let's [ __ ]
quit
but they do incredibly long hours
melissa was always talking about that on
supergirl like
16 18-hour days and when you're the lead
you're there most of the time and the
lead sets the tone yeah top down on
every tv show if the lead is wonderful
to be around the show is wonderful to be
on it'll make tough nights even better
so she's buoyant she never complained
she's a [ __ ] wonderful actress and a
wonderful lead but man i that that girl
like lost sleep she lost time not a lot
a lot of people like she was famous and
she got paid blah blah blah a lot of
other people are famous get paid don't
have to work nearly as [ __ ] hard
as she did on that show and i'm sure the
same goes for i know the same goes for
grant and i never worked with stephen
but i'm sure the same went for steven as
well yeah particularly with [ __ ]
arrow because all of that [ __ ] was at
night like flashlight
during the day supergirl the shoot
during the day but arrow is is it's like
batman they shot that whole [ __ ] at
night they were always on night shoots
yeah
true um oh sorry i know i'm taking your
time i really apologize uh
vfs grad you've graduated yeah yeah
you're you're class 25 yeah what are you
doing mayday crumbling of a doc yes was
a huge inspiration for my class i was
class 77 oh [ __ ] and i did ralph dig
that crazy bongo beat
which uh
similarly
[ __ ] fell apart while you were making
the doc yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah cause
it's like you know you don't know your
classmates you just you're meeting
people for the first time you're hoping
and you're doing it within the first
four weeks yeah and you were smart and
you got out and you got your money and
you made clerks and you were an
inspiration to so many people like me
to go what what the hell am i doing with
my life i want to do [ __ ] uh so i went
to film school because of you how can i
man so i really really appreciate you
so i i'm i'm sorry i'm going to give the
microphone
gentlemen who actually has
no worries no worries and the strike is
still happening right now
sorry what strike is still happening
right now just yeah but we have like
safe harbor agreements which means any
production that is already in
um has signed a safe harbor agreement
and is in production
is protected from any labor action
meaning
we got our hands tied we can't we can't
really strike but it's getting shut
down yeah we can't shut the show down um
i'm i'm in between shows that's why i'm
here good man well enjoy welcome to
thank you give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen
dgc hey spence spence it's been a red
red hot minute let's give it up for
spence man he's been waiting patiently
very patient
all right defense
we
we [ __ ] [ __ ] teased you we brought
you up here we made you stand there and
cuck us out now it's your time to shine
so i have to mention that my mom is also
a smith from new jersey get out of here
see some summit new jersey i know summit
that was where my uh aunt connie lives
whenever i watch you guys i have a
connection because i'm talking about
whatever but uh and connie related to
his mom what's your mom's name cheryl
pretty sure i [ __ ] her
[Music]
jersey small it's not that small hey
they say incest is best right
i was like a smith why hello
what can we do for you man i just want
to ask you one quick question have you
guys watched uh free guy or the adam
project yet
i haven't watched the adam project what
was the first one free guy and i haven't
watched free guy yet i've seen them both
i haven't you've seen them all i've seen
them though and
fun are they fine looks ryan reynolds
man there's a
awesome
i like ryan very much for that it's the
first i think maybe the first cinematic
crossover between
mcu and star wars
which one free guy free guy and yeah is
that what what is it what are you
talking about it's a video game movie
but you would still you'd still find i
would still enjoy it yeah because
there's there's some really good
especially the third act you'd [ __ ]
be like holy [ __ ] they did this all
right it's [ __ ] like it's just it's
free on streaming now yeah it's on uh
hbo max and disney plus right now but
yeah there's a scene where you'd be like
you'd probably come your pants mostly
well now i'm going home fast yeah just
remember spencer told you about this
thing but also
yeah
a ball
at the end of which one adam project
yeah through adam projects is emotional
both of them are really good but all
right i'm gonna watch it also also a
good reason to watch him is because sean
levy is directing to pull three
and sean levy did he direct both of
those yep adam project and the other
yeah they're both what else has he done
he's he did the
knight
he did real skills he was connected with
uh stranger things
for the first season did he also do
museum movies the night and yeah
and yeah he did he produced uh stranger
things right yeah 21 laps as his
production company and they're behind
yeah stranger things
um all right i will give it a shot
again i like him so i don't know why
i've avoided it yeah you'd love it trust
me but
yeah oh anyways my question uh
since both of you uh worked on motu
together and um i really enjoyed it but
can you think of anything from your
childhood either toys
movies or anything you enjoyed
um that you would like to work on
together maybe or in the future just
just nostalgia pretty much
when i was a kid i played with these
toys and i think they would make great
[ __ ] movies but i've never seen it
happen yet i had all these star wars
figures
i'd love it if they let us play with
that um what what toys did i play with
that i think could like work mattel made
a line of toys called big jim remember
those
yeah doll he wasn't as tall as g.i joe
he was about that tall and he was an
adventurer in fact masters of the
universe the only reason they have a
cringer
is because they made tigers for this big
gym set they repainted it and threw it
in there so
um i had this big gym karate dojo
like playset where you could break a
wall and break boards and [ __ ] like that
i had a big gym camper
and he was just by himself there was no
like lady gym or something like that it
was him in the wilderness and adventure
um but the name big jim is just so like
it sounds like a movie like you know
[ __ ] sounds low hey
i would like if we could work on big big
sounds like a dirk diggler production it
really does
people like you went to porn finally i
was like yes
pretty much chest rockwell and big gym
uh i i would like to do i'd like to
remake megaforce oh [ __ ] deeds not words
deeds not words ace hunter yeah um i
loved that movie so much barry bostwick
barry boswick purses combata yes that's
right after star trek her with hair with
hair but it seems as if like they had
had a bunch of team america toys lying
around that they were just going to
paint like camouflage but desert
camouflage
and and sell them and it never worked
because nobody saw megaforce but nerds
who saw it now you got to jump the dirt
bike onto the back of the jets yeah
that's all the [ __ ] thing
so
i get the reference i'm so glad you
mentioned that
but yeah i loved it today it was on the
back of every comic book that i ever
bought as a kid literally gonna say that
for a long period of time it was on the
back of every key issue of comics from
the 80s i think yeah and so i feel like
there's there's a world in which you
could do the coolest dumbest version
of megaforce but still have the same
heart
like it almost wants to be like team
america i was gonna say you know america
is perfect
but uh but no i think with less puppet
[ __ ]
like
a little bit less yeah just a quarter
less family picture you gotta have
[ __ ] that's the only reason
people leave and go to the theaters
these days yeah but i remember being a
kid and i had a i had a huffy huffy was
the the limousine of dirt bikes um when
i was a kid
and so i was like all right i got my
[ __ ] huffy and then i saw a mega
force i'm like here's what we got to do
guys i need a bunch of bottle rockets
that i can tape to the front bar of my
huffy so i could shoot down missiles
in the bronx there's a ton of missiles
in the bronx and but i wanted it so bad
so i could pop wheelies and then light
the bottle rockets and then fire them
into the air you you were the living
definition of deeds not words
and uh and
and found a way to almost blow my hands
off
because when you tape a bottle rocket to
your bike it doesn't do the thing it's
supposed to do which is leave before it
explodes
it just
smokes and then turns into a rail of
fire on the top of your bike and my
parents were like what the [ __ ] are you
doing it's like well cause i'm ace
hunter dad
he's like oh
who the [ __ ] is ace hunter you know
barry bostwick
the guy from [ __ ]
what's that
movie um
um rocky horror pictures rocky horror
pictures i kept wanting to say a little
shop of horrors but i knew that wasn't
it
he was the mayor in spin city too wasn't
he that's right he was the mayor in spin
city
um so yes i would want him to remake
mega megaforce with kevin i think we
would have the most fun are we allowed
to
um
pick
anything yeah can it be a horror movie
[ __ ] yeah i would like to make a horror
movie based on the farmer says
this is
you know where you pull the string and
oh okay oh cow says move
um make our killer
a guy who carries one of those
because i'm sure it'll help sell a bunch
to children and uh
before he kills [ __ ] he pulls
the string and it says like the [ __ ]
horses na and then he kills the person
the way a horse would die or something
like that every animal themed death
around the thing the cow says die yes
in fact that's the title all right yes
the cows has died i can see what are
they called it's not the farmer says
it's the speak no not
well speaking spell is what e.t [ __ ]
with to get home it's not that right
it's
i don't know because it's not about
spelling that was a device that you
actually what is it called cnc
see and say well done give it up for her
she remembered my choice
it's
see and slay
we're halfway there kids
we're halfway there we got a title
scene you're getting co-writing credit
uh what a great question give it up for
spence bench get your canvas on get your
adorable
oh god man pleasure
i feel like we could walk into blumhouse
tomorrow with sea and slay and sleep
give us five million dollars like get
done [ __ ] hot title right
the cow says
that's the trailer right there
um bamf man
light bright the movie
[ __ ] hey i would see that and [ __ ] is
it a horror movie no they [ __ ] put
them in people's eyes and [ __ ] and
they're like ah it's like a little kid
makes pictures and they come to life was
like some of that adam project [ __ ]
i'm looking for violence
um ladies and gentlemen uh we have ran
out of material for this week man you
all have a good time
we went a while man we started the show
at 7 30. it's now 10 40 so it's three
hour [ __ ] show 8 30 30. 8 30
2 10 still pretty two hour and ten show
way bigger in my head
that's what she said yes no doubt
um we don't get to do this show unless
we got a place to do it man and we do it
right here in the scum and villainy
cantina in hollywood and hollywood
boulevard give it up for us coming to
villainy's very own jc
man himself
um
about
seven days from now week from tomorrow
may the fourth
that's right kids may the 4th
is a you know obviously a national
holiday in our world and stuff and here
at scum and villainy cantina is the only
way to spend [ __ ] may the 4th man uh
what are you doing this year uh we're
opening at 10 a.m
jesus christ you can play hooky from
work look at that uh wake up get drunk
it's just a party what day of the week
is it uh wednesday wednesday i feel like
people are still got like flex work from
home schedules work from here true uh
we're gonna do uh star wars trivia at 11
a.m okay
uh hosted by
a former george lucas fan film award
winner and uh jett lucas
look at you and uh anything special on
the
drink menu got a special drink menu so
you can come in and enjoy a qui-gon gin
and juice
that's adorable some other things like
that that was our best seller last year
so we're bringing it back and uh
it's gonna it's always fun it's crazy
the news always shows up and
comes in here
yeah ain't no party like a star wars
party particularly that star wars party
is right here that's coming villainy
cantina may the fourth do they have to
make reservations no it's uh it unlike
the other place it's no reservations and
it's free to walk in well done well done
throwing a little shade at the same time
i see
um okay so that's may the fourth uh may
7th and eighth if you're back east uh
jane sam bob secret stash silver
anniversary bash i'll be there for that
this weekend coming up i'll be in
cincinnati no cleveland for cleveland
fan expo where are you going to be i'm
going to be in los angeles all right so
if you're looking for mark probably made
his wee work office you never can tell
or my new job on the disney [ __ ] lot
that's right man [ __ ] just
walking around with the mouse houses oh
yeah what kind of trouble i can get into
here did you find out anything about
walt disney they really cryogenically
freeze them yes
holy [ __ ] you heard it here first ladies
and gentlemen like day one they tell you
that in orientation like right there sit
down
yeah he's frozen you're like wait got
him right here
um we also get a huge assist
uh on the show it'd be one
simple angle the whole time we're not
for andrew in the back give it up for
andrew andrew
but there is no show without the man
sitting next to standing next to me uh
to my left ladies and gentlemen we could
sit yeah we yeah who knew that was an
option could you imagine we sat in
chairs and just saw this of us for
kilroy the whole show
um
there is no show without this guy give
it up for marvelous mark bernard and
ladies and gentlemen
and that is fat man beyond for this week
i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard
next week same fat time same fat channel
smartguest.com or youtube.com kevin
smith jeff's kiss everybody good night
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith